hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and today I will
be addressing the latest epic
developments in the boku no hero story
in what could easily become the best MHA
arc to date one of the high-end nomu
just did something that I think is
extremely important I think that this
nomu is unique and it's unusual
abilities are a clear warning about
what's to come on top of that the
new-and-improved shigaraki is an
absolute monster the changes that were
made to him are terrifying and by the
looks of it this new shigaraki is about
to awaken very soon we need to talk
about all of that and more so let's get
into it by the way you guys know that we
cover a bunch of different anime series
on this channel and there's been some
debate on our social media recently
about which of the series that we cover
is the fan favorite among our fans so in
order to settle it once and for all
we're going to see which of our videos
can get the most likes if you're on Team
boku no hero definitely leave a like and
let's see if we can hit something crazy
like 15,000 likes and of course if you
want us to keep the content going don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications finally as I always say
this video will contain boku no hero
manga spoilers we are dealing with the
latest developments in the series so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned now the previous installment
of the story ended with endeavors fiery
entrance into the battle of the secret
lab he shows up just as miracle is
facing her toughest challenge yet
the numerous high end normal who are
getting stronger and faster as more time
passes from the moment that they were
awakened in spite of her best efforts
and her incredible strength speed and
bravery Madoka was beginning to lose the
fight against these relentless
artificial humans and her life was in
grave danger thankfully endeavor shows
up just in time or at least that's what
we're led to believe the latest chapter
begins a few moments before this happens
and we are shown just how endeavor and a
bunch of other heroes made their way to
the secret
they followed the trail of no move
through the hospital until they found a
shortcut this shortcut eventually led
them to the area where the entrance to
the lab is located but once they got
there they realized that one of the high
ends was blocking the entrance to the
lab as you will recall that high-end
nomu used some sort of extremely
powerful regeneration quark on top of
some sort of engorging quark in order to
basically block the entire entrance with
its own massive body the number 6 pro
hero crust has been trying to break
through the door in order to help
miracle for some time unfortunately
crust wasn't having much luck with this
particular high-end the regenerative
abilities of this nomal are just too
opie and so the nomu is able to
regenerate faster than crust can damage
it thankfully and ever shows up and
tells everyone not to worry then
Aizawa present mic and a few other
heroes arrived right behind endeavour
Aiza was able to cancel out the engorge
no mousse regeneration quark and
endeavour proceeds to blast the nomu out
of the doorway this allows endeavour
Aizawa present mic crust and a few other
heroes to enter the lab and finally give
some much-needed support to miracle as
endeavour stomps out the high end he
notices that there were dozens of layers
of bones beneath its skin these
creatures were created for the explicit
purpose of being as strong and durable
as possible and clearly a lot of detail
went into their construction Aizawa then
tells endeavoured that he couldn't erase
the quirk of the nomu who was attacking
Miracle on the other end of the lab
because the other two nomu the female
nomu and the nomal with the elephant
nose are blocking the way and never
tells
Aizawa and the other heroes to finish
those two nomu as quickly as possible
while he rushes off to help miracle in
her fight against the extremely stubborn
Super Buu nomu over in the other part of
the lab miracle was able to locate
shigaraki Stubbe right away because her
body told her that something dangerous
was in there in fact her rabbit
instincts screamed at her that she
gareki cannot be allowed to exit his
tube he is far too dangerous as we see a
glimpse of shigaraki inside the watery
tube here
appears to be smiling it looks like he
has a small smirk on his lips and this
might imply that he is actually awake
and aware of what has been going on at
least partially during this chapter she
Guara keys procedure completion rate
jumps from 74 percent to 76 percent and
miracle knows that they must stop she
gotta keep from waking up at all costs
we all knew that she Guara key was
already insanely opie when his quirk
awakened or reawakened back during the
my villain academia our and we all knew
that this mysterious secret procedure is
bound to make him even stronger but this
is our first real indication of just how
terrifying she Gaddafi's transformation
is every instinct in miracles' body was
screaming at her that they have to
prevent shigaraki from getting out at
all costs if he gets out all hell is
going to break loose if he gets out the
fight might already be over and all of
the work that the heroes put into
planning these raids will be for nothing
the new shigaraki and the villains will
usher in a completely different world
and many will die as a result this is
the new reality that the current war arc
seems to be preparing us for back at the
entrance to the lab the waifu high end
is fighting it out with present mike
crusts
Aizawa and other heroes and something
extremely important happens during this
showdown between the female high end and
the heroes we clearly see just how
different this female nomu is from the
other no mood that we've seen up to this
point she quickly realizes that she
hasn't been able to use her quirk for
some reason and she almost instantly
figures out that the reason why she
can't use her quirk is Aizawa she also
quickly realizes how exactly aizawa's
quirk erasing ability works since she
hasn't made physical contact with Aizawa
and since Aizawa is hiding his eyes the
secret of his power must lie in his
sight so the female normal uses her
incredible speed to retreat and
disappear from Iowa's line of sight
thereby escaping the erasing effect of
his
quirk now the nature of Iowa's quirk
might be obvious to us because we've
known him for so long but this female
gnome who just met Iowa for the very
first time mere moments ago and yet she
was able to figure out what exactly he
is doing and adjust her behavior
accordingly
within seconds not to mention how clear
and sophisticated her inner thoughts
appeared to be even among the high-end
that we've seen so far this female
normal seems to be unbelievably
intelligent this is potentially
approaching kudo giddy levels of quick
thinking and intelligence in my opinion
which means that this female nomu might
be special even among the high ends this
high end might have more in common to
kudo giri than the other know mode that
we've met so far now I've said this
before but my theory for why kudo giddy
is so intelligent is that he wasn't
created from a corpse he was created
from a person who was still alive at the
time I think that Alberto survived the
accident that supposedly killed him but
he was of course gravely injured
Yuko then faked obras death and used his
still living body to create kudo giddy i
also believe that this female nomu might
share the same origins she may have been
created from a living person not a
corpse as the female gnome who
disappears behind the tubes its head and
body begin to feel clearer and it
appears that she is now finally becoming
fully awake this means that she is about
to get even more powerful and
potentially even more intelligent she
then uses two quirks called barrage and
acid simultaneously in order to launch a
massive acid attack at the pro heroes
the attack appears to have done some
damage to the heroes and even endeavours
arm looks like it was damaged by the
acid this is still happening in the
moment before endeavour rushes off to
help miracle back at the other end of
the lab Madoka is doing her very best to
ruin you Chico's day by stopping
whatever it is that he is doing with
shigaraki Fujiko is still scared and he
still has boogers flowing from his nose
but unfortunately the super boo nomu the
Nomo who
quark Aizawa was unable to erase grabs
miracle yet again the no move stops
miracle from finishing the job and it
doesn't look good for miracle at this
point the super boo Nomo seems to have a
firm grip on the already injured miracle
and it looks like her life might be in
mortal danger this is the point at which
I began screaming internally because I
love miracles so much she's easily in my
top five favorite MHA characters already
so I am sending all of my positive
energy to her and hoping that she will
survive I said this before but crust and
some of the other heroes I would
understand if they have to go I respect
them but I would understand but I will
not accept anything bad happening to the
bunny queen miracle and if that makes me
a simp for a fictional 2d character then
so be it it's still better than sipping
over anyone who is in 3d thankfully
endeavour storms in and rescues miracle
from the clutches of the Super Buu nomu
and this sends ug Co into another
boogery panic attack bro this has not
been a good day for you G Co at this
rate he will soil himself and have a
heart attack at the same time and never
calls out to me to cope but she doesn't
waste any time talking about herself or
her injuries she immediately reveals she
got Rocky's location and she screams at
endeavor to kill him and Fujiko no
matter what happens they cannot let
shigaraki wake up they have to prevent
that from happening at all cost and that
is how this chapter ends and to me this
appears to be an absolutely crucial
chapter a turning point chapter the
scene in which we got to see the female
normals train of thought was very
important in my opinion it shows that
she is special even among the high ends
and this no mo in particular will likely
be the key to understanding the truth
about kudo getting beyond that this
chapter has given us a terrifying
glimpse into Shiga Rocky's insane
transformation the new shigaraki will
not just be a formidable opponent he is
so dangerous that allowing him to awaken
could mean the end
for the heroes at this point we have to
assume that Shigure Aki could
single-handedly ruin this raid and bring
about the end of the hero society the
level of desperation that the extremely
brave and fierce musical shows when it
comes to the need to stop shigaraki
tells us everything we need to know the
new shigaraki is an absolute monster
and after he emerges from the tube
things will never be the same again to
be honest I'm really conflicted about
shigaraki now because I definitely want
to see him awaken and I want him to
demonstrate his new insane power but at
the same time I don't want him to
actually kill any of my favourite
characters including of course miracle
oh man this arc is getting so intense on
the one hand I am loving the hype and
the action but on the other hand I am
becoming increasingly worried for the
safety of so many great characters let
me know what you guys think
is she gonna keep going to awaken and
actually kill any major characters or
are the heroes going to succeed in
preventing that from happening also am I
the only one simple hard for miracle or
are there more of us team bunny queen
stands out there drop a hashtag bunny
queen down in the comments if you're
part of the miracle simp crew if you
enjoyed this video and you wanna see
more videos like it please don't forget
to leave a like let's see how many boku
no hero fans are on this channel and if
you happen to be new to anime up lore or
you just haven't subscribed yet please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications by the way if you like the
visuals in my videos and you're glad
that you don't have to listen to my
voice over a blank screen please show
some love to my visual editor core he
makes quality anime content on his
channel as well so definitely check him
out link in the description I want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for supporting our work
and making these videos possible special
thank you to baby R a disciple of Lord
we go himself another big thank you to
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
in grata alone Adam the world stealers
the school bus Tyson
II know a quad respect and putt a heffa
and I can't forget our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell drous Anatole Cassatt's key on
hell Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor
cricket XP Ted no Ted Salter Jose
Stanton very Gucci alicia ahktar animal
is 69
Jessica Kayla fond emperor otaku JCCC
waka and the coach if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you please consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]